now we're not all lucky enough to have a
fully stocked bar at home I'm going to
show you the basics to get you started
there's three categories sweet sour a
carbonation now sweet
we've got sugar if you want to get fancy
add a little bit honey to your cocktail
it's really floral now if you're lucky
enough to get your hands on some agave
syrup it's rich vibrant it will put your
cocktails on another level
the most commonly known sour ingredients
are lemons and limes
now grapefruit I love again adds a
little sourness to it when you take that
zest off it will act as a beautiful
garnish if you're really fancy get hold
of some yuzu juice imagine combining
lemons limes orange grapefruit and some
floral notes as well now that is a game
changer for your cocktails you need
carbonation first one we will start with
is club soda the axe is like a blank
canvas tonic water is not for everybody
quinine is that flavor in it whether
it's that kind of bitter note to it but
it can actually be using cocktails as
well not just for your gin and tonic
ginger beer you may have seen ginger
beer because of the Moscow Mule what I
love about it is the spicy notes to it
now you may not have every ingredient in
a bar but if you have one of each of
these you're off to a great start
there's more cocktail videos like this
at the GQ channel
you